[Music]
hey it's time again for the matinee show
yeah we saw three of them three new
movies in the theater although we saw
two in the theater this week and one we
saw already and then one was a new
Netflix movie yeah so that's how we're
rolling now yeah where's the time of the
three best movies we saw so the first
movie that we saw this week we actually
watched Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
the Quentin Tarantino movie for the
second time because we liked it so much
the first time that we have a list this
dubs a-list thing so we figured hey
nothing else really started so let's go
see it again and we'll see if we like it
better at the second time and guess what
I did yeah it stood up to multiple
viewings um actually you know what's
funny is that in like the first review I
actually wanted to do like a spoiler
discussion but I guess Tom says no no
okay you know if you want to do it and
do it but we just have to put spoilers
in there yeah I mean I guess we don't
have to but um yeah so what I was gonna
say that when I was like when I reviewed
the movie the first time I think that I
kind of said oh it's very loosely
plotted or like some stuff is kind of
like meandering or doesn't really go
anywhere but when you watch it the
second time that is actually not the
case no it's a tight story there's
actually I mean yeah it's told in a very
you know kind of you know I don't want
to say meandering because that sounds
bad but I mean it it's told in a very
like laid-back sort of way it's not
obvious about what it's doing you have
to pay attention but yeah but it became
much clearer to me the second time
around since I already knew where the
plot was going since I already knew
where everything was going to go so I
could concentrate on other things and
it's actually really like [ __ ] that
characters say at the beginning like his
referenced again later on or went toward
the end there's like a couple of
sequences in the middle like one of
which is like cliff Booth's thing that
he's doing and the other was Rick
Dalton's thing that he's doing and the
second time I saw it I was like oh those
two things are parallel that's why they
put like one that way and then they kind
of cut back and forth between the two
things because I think when I saw it the
first time I didn't really I don't know
I was I did
because I didn't know where it was going
so I didn't really cotton on that that's
what he was doing he was like drawing
parallels between these two men's
journeys like during this foot that was
particularly like in the second act of
the movie yeah it was it was two men who
are good friends that have bit different
strengths and weaknesses and both of
them kind of becoming kind of like self
actualized they're both on a journey
yeah and there's like a parallel journey
right you have a television actor who's
trying to go through the transformation
of becoming a movie star and a real
actor you know and then going along the
same journey is a stuntman who was a war
hero becoming a hero in his local circle
real hero you have one guy who's an
actor and the other guy who's actually a
man of action he's really doing [ __ ]
he's not pretended yeah
you know and I didn't pick yeah and I
didn't pick that up I mean I sort of did
but then I think it was a lot more
obvious to me the second time around
that I'm like oh there's between like a
guy that does real stuff and like an
actor but he's not making a judgement
like no one's better than the other but
he's just showing like a parallel yeah
development and like this how their
story are explaining that I as a society
the fake who's the actor he's getting
all these rewards and Fame and [ __ ] like
that and then the real hero is as
literally an underdog and his friend is
a dog yeah got a dog and he ran out of
like the dog - the actor you'll see you
don't talkative but like I said one
thing that I'll companion one thing that
I like about this and I think we
mentioned before like one of the main
themes of the stories like not only like
oh you know kind of a love letter to
1960s Hollywood and you know second
chances and things like that
but I mean the whole emotional heart of
the movie is the friendship between
these two guys yeah and the thing that's
awesome about is Brad Pitt's character
cliff Boothe it's like he's clearly you
would think that in a lot of movies of
this ilk I would think that that there
would be some kind of rivalry between
the word there would be of like
resentment because like I said you know
he's a war hero he's like you a stuntman
he has to do stuff for real and you
would think that he was like oh here's
this guy that and I have to come in and
do all the heavy lifting for him and you
know what I mean and he just
him to let go hey go fix the antenna my
roof and stuff like that but the cool
thing about cliffs character is that
he's not resentful at all no he's just
like his best friend and he wants the
best for him and and the story is kind
of true to life they were gonna have to
go their separate ways because business
all right
business and life was kind of pulling
them apart but the story ends where
they're kind of their friendship is
bonded together through combat
yeah I have to go to war together to
vanquish a common foe yeah and that a
very literal sense yeah and that kind of
[ __ ] is the big event that solidifies
the friendship evidently for life yeah
the way it's in and then it takes and it
also takes that relationship to the next
level because what they did opened up
doorways in the professional world and
in the social world which is the same
thing really yeah it opened up both of
their futures like I'm very positive of
them just doing what me what guys do
it's very much a guy story very much so
but women love the story you know how
it's the two characters are just so
likeable and their friendship is just so
believable yeah that you know when
you're watching them I just you know I
think it's like kind of like a universal
story a friendship it's not necessarily
been guys or anything like that it's
just you know it's a story of friendship
and loyalty and how these two guys are
on parallel paths but one's not better
than the other ones not resentful of the
other or anything like that they're both
like they're about the same yeah it's
like you do your thing I'm doing my
thing over here and it's like hopefully
it'll turn out good for both of us and
stuff like that so a lot more of that
came through the second time yeah um and
also another thing too was that some
things that I thought kind of didn't
maybe didn't lead anywhere were just
kind of like random kind of [ __ ] like um
you know like the one seen at the party
with like words like Steve McQueen and
stay that where he's like oh that [ __ ]
but yeah there was like a mirror to that
like later on in another scene where
Rick Dalton is talking to another
character like where he says almost the
same things and I was like oh I get it
they were just setting up well they were
setting up two things really but I mean
you
they were setting up something to do
with Rick Dalton's character and then
they were also setting up like kind of a
thing that might happen in the future oh
yeah you know what I mean like after the
movie is over
I don't like Tarantino movies in general
like we saw inglorious basterds it was
not watchable to me I just it's like way
more over the top than I remember I
can't stand that [ __ ] alright but this
particular movie to me is a masterpiece
this is my favorite movie is yeah that's
what I mean like that very Titleist
movie it's a very tight story and it's
very epic in terms of it's got an epic
mythology to this story it's a symbolic
it's mythological but I don't know once
you get to a certain age you start
understanding this kind of movie yeah
you know you know if you're a guy does a
guy story
yeah that's universal but it's also very
masculine he did it [ __ ] on purpose too
and you know they were bonded together
in combat finally at the end and that
reversed kind of the downward trend that
was going in their lives it's pretty
cool pretty cool I liked it and I had
forgotten the second time around I had
forgotten how funny that part of the
movie where Rick is to Italy and they
were like they were making references to
like a tent like spaghetti westerns of
some of those that they said were real
but some of them were made up and like
the the made-up ones I've forgotten how
[ __ ] funny that [ __ ] was they have
all the posters the titles have been I'm
like oh my god they got it like spot on
yeah also a lot of spot-on dialogue
where you have a guy who's a television
actor and he doesn't want to become a
spaghetti western star because spaghetti
westerns suck saying they say and mostly
they did that's what you would have
known back then but you know what I mean
Clint Eastwood hadn't happened yet
though yeah and good and bad and the
ugly hadn't happened yet so really the
story is telling you that this fictional
character is actually getting into a
brand new genre that could actually
propel a career to newer heights like it
did for Eastwood yeah you know and
that's what the meaning of the story is
at the end of the story because he makes
friends with Roman Polanski you know
that on the back of his
Italian film career he can now go into
Polanski movies yeah that's what they're
talking about yes they're like they
don't say but that's like the implicit
that's the implication and that's what
it means in this story and another thing
too is that you know the more I'm
getting into this movie and if you go to
this the AV Club site they did a big
long article called once upon a time in
Hollywood annotated and they all went in
there and were like talking about all
the different references that Quentin
Tarantino about all the different TV
shows like which ones are real which
ones are fake like who are all the you
know people like who was that poster and
Brad Pitt's trailer who was Anne Francis
from Forbidden Planet by the way cuz I
didn't recognize her at first
you know Robert Goulet singing on the TV
and all this other kind of stuff and the
more than I read into it I I mean I knew
that Quentin Tarantino was like a film
fanatic it's like and he knows all he
knows pretty much everything like really
obscure [ __ ] - like from TV and movies
and everything he knows like everything
about that he is like an encyclopedic
knowledge of it but until I was reading
this article I didn't realize just how
many tendrils that he had put into this
movie and it wasn't just kind of like a
wink-wink hey check this out kind of
thing it's like a lot of the references
he made in there were commenting on Rick
Dalton's character art yeah that's why
he picked that particular song that's
why he picked that particular movie
trailer that's why he picked that any
other thing and so like at what I was
reading that I was like I had like a
whole new like admiration for the movie
just because of all the detail that he
put in there that was commenting on the
story like in a subtle sort of way now
we're doing good it kind of stand clear
spoilers I think but I want to mention
Bruce Lee yeah a friend of mine I grew
up with he's into martial arts he oh
dude if you follow me on Tom's shitty
movies lately you'll see that I've been
messing around with martial arts I grew
up with guys that were in martial arts
my friend of mine you know he ended up
becoming a paramedic and my step-brother
was a [ __ ] two-time black belt in
Taekwondo and he was badass he could
kick your ass you know he I watched him
kick their four guys ass
and another guy you know they kind of
were good another guy came in who's a
real good friend of mine named Jace and
he kind of got upset at betrayal of
Bruce Lee in this I think Bruce Lee's
daughters gotta piss yeah yeah but
here's the thing you know I did some
research on this on this subject I don't
want to spoil everything that happened
but Bruce Lee and Booth enter into a
friendly sparring contest to see who
could knock another one down on their
ass
yeah all right it went in a unexpected
way okay but everything I've been able
to find out about Bruce Lee the way he
went you know Bruce Lee was not a
professional fighter but Chuck Norris
said he was a fantastic fighter
yeah but he got hired on to the Green
Hornet so early he didn't have to make a
living fighting but he Norris trained
with him and you know Norris said that
both he and Bruce were good even though
Bruce only weighed 135 pounds Bruce
could punch [ __ ] hard and he was
extremely fast and Bruce was training
for what was needed at the time
you know Norris said that you know had
MMA been around it they both would have
trained for that and that they both
would have been good at MMA yeah okay
it's just that you know Bruce was
training he was kind of making prototype
MMA you know putting things together you
know he knew about you know ground up
groundwork and you know holds you know
he knew all about that casas but in this
movie I don't want to say that Bruce Lee
was defeated it's just that this
stuntman held his own against yes Lee
and some people don't really like that
but what that did to the story is it
gives it gives booth the credibility he
needed as a veteran war hero to do what
he does in the very end of the movie
yeah it's just like a four shot it's a
foreshadow in it there was that that
booth wasn't really
some dude having a good time and they
keep showing he's got scars all over his
body from [ __ ] battle wounds from I
guess the Second World War you know some
of them might have been from the stuff
man and stop man stuff - okay
so what they're trying to say is that
booth could hold his own in a
competition against Bruce Lee so you're
not talking about average guy yeah so
it's like they were trying to pump up
the believability later on that he would
be able to that he could do some [ __ ] do
what he did at the end yeah so yeah and
the thing too is that and I had kind of
forgotten about this until I saw the
movie again but you know that you know
that one big scene with Bruce Lee and
Brad Pitt's character they actually
showed Bruce Lee a couple more times
later on in the movie training with Jay
Sebring who's Sharon Tate's friend and
also trading Sharon Tate for the movie
the Wrecking Crew and those two things
actually did happen Jay Sebring did
train with Bruce Lee and briefly did
help train Sharon Tate yeah you know in
the martial arts that she did in that
movie the wrecking crew which is a real
lady but and there have been guys that
you know came up in that same period
with Bruce Lee and Bruce Lee of course
he wasn't a pro fighter but evidently he
was a hell of a street fighter if he
wouldn't allow himself to be
disrespected I mean you know there was
some guy he got into scuffles yeah so I
think you know how he's portrayed in the
movie based on people that knew him in
martial arts and debt that's about how
he was I think that was a fair
representation not all these guys like
you know this is the 60s there wasn't
all this high-minded Zen Jedi Knight
stuff you know no you pissed the dude
off you could get punched in those days
that's how it man back then you
challenged a man he would answer your
challenge and Bruce Lee movies were like
that yeah so you know what I mean yeah
if you challenge Bruce Lee he'd probably
he says we're not gonna hurt each other
okay but we're gonna though no punching
no punching in the face you know but
evidently there was some tales some guys
that can I can't remember the guys name
but there was one guy that saw some
action at parties that yeah he put she'd
knock you on your ass if he came at him
I believe it yeah well I've seen all of
Bruce Lee's movies and it's like he's a
little dude but he he is all mussed he's
like solid muscle
I don't think there's an ounce of fat
yeah yeah he was there was no fat on
that dudes body the only way a hundred
thirty-five pounds but he was extremely
lean and very well conditioned muscle
you could look at his torso and his arms
and his legs he was very fast and
according to everybody who sparred with
him you know and saw him and trained
with him like Chuck Norris I said that
he could hit amazingly hard yeah so he
knew how to twist a punch in on you you
know well if you get fast yeah it's just
kind of like when people like when
people [ __ ] on like like ballet dancers
and [ __ ] like I'm like I wouldn't want
to get kicked by a blade probably knock
your [ __ ] head off good good friend
good friend of mine Wiis from from the
Barot I'm calling little swell little
slow his older brothers were all a
semi-pro boxers and they just used him
as a punching bag and this dude can
[ __ ] he can he can fight and he's
about 5 foot probably 5 foot 4 and can
land 3 or 4 solid
blows into your face before you even
knew that the first one hit well like it
sounds like a machine gun I think you
got some dudes in the pizza place yeah
two Irish guys here there was much
bigger than him yeah pizza place and he
just knocked about and walked away
before the cops noticed which you know
right next the police station shot
involved yeah yeah that pizza place is
like literally it's like a parking lot
and then there's the bleep rap left them
there sleeping on the ground they didn't
know what happened well yeah because
that you know everybody would just think
oh they just got drunk and yeah passed
out cuz it happens downtown oh yeah so
you can't judge somebody skill and speed
has a lot to do with it no they didn't
know yeah definitely and little swollen
hammy fear he's a psycho and I got the
video all right so like I'm saying if
you haven't seen Once Upon a Time in
hollywood yet if you're a Quentin
Tarantino fan anything like that
seriously this is something that really
it's moving the camera stop it pokey
okay um this is something that really
benefits from a second viewing because
you catch so much stuff that you miss
the first yeah it's a lot deeper and you
know what something else that
I didn't know like the first time we saw
the movie I was thinking you know where
they're driving around like the streets
of LA and it's 1969 I thought that was
all CGI most of it's not they said what
they did was that they would rope off
like one section of street one and they
had their set designers pretty much go
over all of the buildings that are still
there like and make that make it look
just like it did in 1969 so that's most
of that is actually there and the
soundtrack is awesome yeah I want the
soundtrack yes like oh I especially love
the that cover of California dream and
then doing there I think it's Jose
Feliciano and yeah it's really cool like
and I like that the whole sequence were
there having around at night and stuff
you know I was born in 69 in California
but a lot of the stuff that they show I
remember for if it was still there you
know they remember from van de Kamp's
restaurants and those old taco bells and
that old just der Wienerschnitzel I know
right where that was there was lots of
those back in the day but I think that
was the one out Long Beach yeah I'm
telegin I think that was near Long Beach
but so either something correct me if
I'm wrong I think it was the one right
there near the near the pike yeah but
yeah you know it's funny cuz looking at
it my childhood it when I was five six
seven things still looked like that well
yeah that was only a few years like a
few years later but that's that was kind
of the environment I grew up in and that
was during the time we were stealing
gasoline from dad's you know lawn mower
and trying to go down into the dam flood
control systems to go fight the giant
lucky we didn't see the Terminator
because it turned a few years later the
terminators yeah back when in fact when
all the children were feral Def Con all
children were feral young kids wouldn't
understand it
hey whoo it's a shotgun that's it like
that you're like ten with the shotgun go
blow some [ __ ] yeah go get the shotgun
yeah we still us yeah yeah but yeah
check it out and definitely I think this
is definitely one we need to buy when it
comes out yeah because this is this is
one that I can see myself just
revisiting I put this as Tarantino's
best movie BAM right underneath it I
would probably put Pulp Fiction yeah
underneath that I'd pry
pull Reservoir Dogs True Lies
Naturalizer a true romance you just
wrote that he was routed in directed by
prime gonna consider that a Tarantino
flick though it has a lot of you know
and again I haven't seen it for many
years yeah I prefer romance and then
underneath that Reservoir Dogs yeah and
then the other ones is just you random
because I don't like any other ones yeah
some people might like him hateful eight
wasn't bad as I say it again yeah it
needs a rewatch cuz I wasn't like super
paying attention to it the whole time I
was watching their Zoe come on Reservoir
Dogs there's like that happening in a
cabin yeah it was like a bottle movie
yeah and stuff I'd like to see it again
yeah so maybe I put hateful eight under
the bottom of the good ones yeah but I
think this is a masterpiece yeah
honestly and and I think like I said
seeing it a second time
I mean I loved it the first time but the
second time when I caught all the
connections and all the mirroring and
all this stuff like going back and forth
to one another and so it just made it
like such a riches it's very tricky and
masterpiece moment yeah or uh for
Tarantino yes I I feel like I mean I
haven't seen
I love Pulp Fiction I don't I might like
this better than Pulp Fiction just like
oh yeah I don't know but I haven't
decided like I said I have to see Pulp
Fiction again they're like really cement
fiction has certain problems with it and
with the acting I don't want you know to
mean Pulp Fiction is kind of an excuse
for Tarantino to use the N word around
[ __ ] samuel l.jackson if you ask me
true there's a lot of stuff in there the
acting is is not good in certain parts
samuel l.jackson and oh boy
[ __ ] what's his name John Travolta
they'd blow it out of the water well
they're the bad part uma Thurman does
stuff and then the dude that played is
the the black dude from Mission
Impossible he did played the gangster he
was [ __ ] fantastic
yeah remember the one word or I won't
take missile rapists you know what was
yeah yeah Ving Rhames Ving Rhames yeah
he's fantastic in the movie
everybody was it's just there a certain
Quentin doesn't need to be in his own
movies
yeah alright he seems to have gotten
over that
yeah he's a director even he's an idea
man he's not an actor but it's kind of
good because I feel like you know his
early movies are really good then there
were some in the middle that were like
just okay but then this one is like um
it came out it is amazing so I think
that's like that's good I almost put
this up there with the shining up there
with [ __ ] 2001 a Space Odyssey I'm
gonna put this up there with a Kubrick
Ian masterpiece
okay that's out that's very high yeah
it's coming from Tom because you know he
doesn't like anything and he's a
director that I don't particularly like
all that much yeah but this one is
[ __ ] yeah I'm actually really glad
you liked this one because I never know
what movies he's gonna like or not
because sometimes he surprises make us
sometimes I'm watching it and I'm the
whole time and I'm thinking like sounds
good
it's movie then this is six out of five
stars
damn six out of five listen to that you
guys so I'm gonna give him a bonus star
this is like I say it's a fantastic
movie I mean it seems like it's doing
really well like it's got like amazing
reviews it is not for everybody
true it's not for everybody it's like I
said this is a slice-of-life movie but a
Kubrick Ian slice-of-life movie about
the 60s late 60s in California in
Hollywood it's a kind of like a bromance
movie with a mythological symbolism
involved in it in the story you you know
either you're gonna like it or you're
not yeah like I said I feel like some
people might think it's too slow or
whatever but it's like yeah I'm a kind
of coming because it can kind of come
across as a movie about nothing in a way
like I said it is a hangout movie but
there's study there is stuff going on in
there yeah yeah it's it's in a way very
realistic yeah yeah but yeah it's about
it's about character development of
dudes that are buddies yeah and certain
and a dog and Varion and dog it was very
relatable yeah I mean I really liked it
a lot and like I said this this is
definitely one I think we should buy
because I want to watch this one or if I
get this [ __ ] on steelbook and watch
all the extra features and yeah and like
I said go to AV Club and check out if
you liked this movie go check out that
article that they were at where they
talk about all the difference it's no
wonder you can be blasted and watch it
and still just yeah it's fine alright so
yeah check it out
you
okay the second movie we saw for our
matinee show this week was a Netflix
movie called soul to keep yeah it wasn't
bad now most of the stuff online says it
came out in two thousand two thousand
eighteen which I guess it did because I
guess it did like the festival like
horror festival circuit but it only just
came to Netflix in I think it was July
1st 2019 so that was one of the ones
that we had on our list to watch for
this year and it wasn't uh not bad at
all I mean it was obviously it's a very
low-budget movie there actually isn't a
lot of information about it online it
doesn't even have a Wikipedia page it
had a good cast the acting and it was
pretty it was pretty good it was shot
competently it was shot well story was
interesting it was a lot like a movie
from back our move from the horror movie
from back when we were kids probably
written a little bit better yeah like
from the eighties from the 80s or
something had a Evil Dead kind of yeah
coming evil did yeah not bad at all we
you know the quality of the way it
looked came out nice you know it's hard
to tell a little budget movie nowadays
because anybody can make high quality
everything so cheap Chifa did so it
looked it looked good yeah it's
basically I mean the story behind it um
it's just this big group of friends and
two of them itthere a brother and sister
I think they're supposed to be twins
even though they don't really look that
much alike and they have inherited their
grandfather's house after he supposedly
died now the grandfather supposedly
drowned on the property and they never
found the body
so they decide that they're all gonna go
out to this house and it's kind of a
dump you know and they're all gonna go
out there and party so they bring all
the booze all the drugs they brought the
DJ thing they brought the party lights
they were not [ __ ] around I don't
know where for some reason I thought
this movie might be Canadian but I don't
know if it is but it's somewhere like
out in the wilderness it looked like
Canada or Washington State or something
like that and then they all drive up
there and they find in the basement they
find like a little bit of one of them
grimoire things and since one of the
girls with them is a Wiccan goth chick
you
so that's worse she's got to get in here
and this is the draw of the movie it's
God you got a cute redhead goth chick
who gets possessed by the devil or a TV
Elphaba Beelzebub and she does all kinds
of sexual [ __ ] and then she just and
then other people get possessed and
that's why you see this movie not I mean
that's very much an evil dead late
sometimes wacky but um it's very much
that kind of thing where it's like they
read from a forbidden book cuz
everybody's like drunk and their daring
each other it's like oh that's let's
summon some demons in there but on HBO
when I was a kid that didn't have loved
it yeah like I said it's nothing you
haven't seen before yeah that's the
problem but yeah but it's you know you
the the only kind of thing that I
thought was kind of cool about it was
that one of the characters and she's
played by an actress named Sandra Mae
Frank who's actually a Broadway actress
I learned and she's deaf and she's deaf
and real life so she's playing a deaf
character and so a lot of the movie I
mean she's obviously speaking in ASL but
all the other characters do too which I
thought was kind of cool I'm like hey
all her friends learn to ASL so she
wouldn't be like left out of their
conversations they're just talking and
like doing sue she knows what they're
saying right and the interesting thing
too is that the guy that's in this the
actors name is Craig Fogle now when we
were watching this movie he's kind of
like annoying at the beginning he's one
of those like I have a vlog with 60
followers that I have to run I have to
do all this stuff in my camera but I
said man that dude looks just like
Robert Englund I said is that his son
just like Freddie he looked just like
and the character's name is Freddie yeah
and I was like well okay now are they
making a joke that he actually is Robert
England's kid or they just like they
realized that he looks like him so they
thought it would be funny to didn't
there he didn't have the same last we
have the same last name it's like if he
is Robert England's kid he's either like
a bastard child or he doesn't want
anyone to know looks just like him he
looks exactly like a very young girl but
like I was freaking out and like
especially like you know after he starts
making like all these distorted faces
I'm like a god so it's like I didn't
know but I looked him up and apparently
he's been in like two or three other
movies and he's based out of New York
and he apparently he's also an ASL
interpreter like on Dad's his regular
job so I guess that's why one of the
reasons they wanted this movie to
because they wanted to a cure they could
speak in sign language there isn't a
whole lot to actually say about the
movie I mean it's a it's a competently
executed movie it's got a good cast the
acting is good the idea is a good the
only thing that there's a problem with
these movies is that they all kind of
look the same yeah reality isn't yeah
and you got to realize how hard it is to
come up with the original idea in a
genre where everything has been done
pretty much and because everything's
been done you're just using a bunch of
memes that have always been used over
and over again and then the camerawork
and the filters and everything in the
editing that they use is kind of boiled
down into the way you're supposed to do
it and what that ends up doing is that
the movies kind of all kind of looked a
lot look alike and they have a similar
textures and similar storytelling tempo
you know by the time there's things that
it's almost kind of like going through a
formula well yeah that's kind of the
problem this is the same kind of thing
it's like it's they're all at a spooky
old house they're all partying some of
her annoying some not so much there's a
lot of fake jump scares at the beginning
like you're gonna build up doesn't mean
it's bad no it's perfectly enjoy and
watchable it's just not possible and
maybe it would have been I could
understand that you know they did it
they did it that way because that was
the you're not taking any risks you're
doing it the the right way the way
everybody else is doing it but what ends
up how you're able to sell the product
after you get it done which myths
probably probably a safe call yeah you
know cuz you didn't the movies didn't
get [ __ ] up if you do something super
weird you kind of risk falling rice and
no but then what ends up happening is
that you're taking another risk which is
that people don't remember the movie or
it doesn't stand out yeah and I think
that's kinda what you got here this is
one words you can watch it's enjoyable
but kana in the end it doesn't stand out
from it doesn't stand out from the other
ones which I think kind of happened like
the one we reviewed last week the other
Netflix movie that we did which mercy
black which is like a perfectly good
movie it's like perfectly fine for a
Friday night you sit around get some
pizza and get some booze you sit around
and watch a scary movie but you know a
day or two later you're not gonna
remember anything that happened yeah you
can't forget what happy cuz it's just
like a standard yeah it's a pretty
standard gross and this is like a pretty
standard demon-possession type of movie
kind of like The Evil Dead not like I
said not as a knee or stylistic as that
we love a can you look at the old lady's
movies like that they're just so
handcrafted you can't forget yeah
everything there was a lot of stupid
ones back yeah he was not to save me
ones yeah there was but even even you
can go back now to look at some of the
weird to say anyone's like the stuff
stuff wasn't so shall we say me that was
the [ __ ] weird yeah that was a weird
movie Larry Cohen is kind of in a class
by himself he does some like pretty
weird [ __ ] fit you can go back in you
can go back and see some of the bad
Sammy ones from the eighties and you
don't really forget them because they
stand out as being [ __ ] really bad or
if I could silly or or I remember when
the rubber chicken you know came at you
yeah you can do remember it you know to
me cuz I don't believe a pretty bad
taste in your mouth
remember him yeah yeah that's one thing
even when they were bad they they
weren't really boring oh yeah I mean
look at something like Street trash
right which was like you know it's not a
good movie obviously but it was like the
weirdest it's the concept was just so
weird and it's kind of like a lot of
corporate restaurant food it's not bad
yeah all kind of tastes the same right
so you kind of forget about it and
you'll forget about that restaurant but
you went to a Chinese restaurant it was
[ __ ] terrible you won't forget that
one yeah points that they might laugh
about that one later yeah man that
[ __ ] Chinese food sucks
you might laugh about it later and
that's the way some of the 80s movies
were the fishery I don't know bad that
you laughed at him remember them yeah I
like if we're gonna make a movie I think
it's better to like just go whole ha I
mean if you if you actually get the crew
and the money together and you're
actually we're gonna make a movie man
make something's gonna be remembered
even if it sucks if everybody remembers
it for being terrible like troll 2 or
the room or something like that
everybody remembers your movie though
yeah so I mean somebody will buy that
toaster and put it up on there in there
on the roll cuz that's just sucked or
make something like tusks I'll never
forget that [ __ ] tusks is a
masterpiece man you feel [ __ ] dirty
after watching that [ __ ] for a couple
days you trying to get that out of your
I still haven't watched yoga hosers I
probably do I'm gonna buy tasks that's a
weird [ __ ] movie and like I said I I
liked it because I had no I didn't
really think about it beforehand
somebody just a friend just recommended
it to me so all I knew was the title and
I just weren't so I didn't know have any
idea was I have a seat tusks go go rent
tosses [ __ ] crazy you're either gonna
love it and you're gonna hate it it's a
good movie I liked it well made movie
yeah well made movie this is mine it's
the topic and what happens yeah not as
bad as human centipede but yes nothing
like that or this I'm not saying like
though it's like a Serbian film or
anything like that watching like babies
get raped and she it's nothing like that
but it's yeah it's it's a little bit
eerie settling on satellite yeah in a
weird humerus walruses but yeah so like
I said again like our review of Mercy
black it's this is pretty good if you
like demon-possession movies feel like
Evil Dead you don't have anything better
to do yeah then you could certainly do
worse than watching yeah I come in the
guys that made it yeah that's a very
low-budget movie it's done right you
wouldn't know it was a little budget
movie yeah it's in a buy made money's
are perfectly fine yeah fun movie to
watching was good yeah
okay for the third movie we saw this
week we went back to AMC Theaters and
yeah Fast and Furious presents Hobbs and
Shawn yeah and I've only seen the very
first Fast & Furious I haven't seen any
other ones everything is a [ __ ] ton of
these movies there's like a whole
universe of the movies so we're gonna
review this and you haven't seen them
either
I saw the first one right and then the
first one is just the Dino same
characters it doesn't have anything to
do with this one right so we're just
going in we're so we're gonna review
this movie just on the back of this
movie you don't talk about so you know
this is a movie that you don't have to
see the other ones too to understand
well yeah I mean I'm sure it helps but
yeah there's there's a bunch of
backstory but none of it matters you can
still go and see the movie and enjoy it
yes good movie all that matters is the
action is the fight yep and the car cars
and the step blown up the motorcycle
chases and the guns and the cyborgs and
and it's a very visual and it's [ __ ]
crazy and it's it's got a very good
humor in it it's an action-adventure
movie yeah that's what it is
and it's also I would call it a comedy
pretty much well it's got a good comedia
talis a lot of comedy in yeah well you
have to because so many so much
implausible stuff happens it's cool
can't take this [ __ ] seriously you just
go and have a good time the [ __ ] rock
knocks it out of the park he's always
awesome in whatever movie I've ever seen
him in and what's a look at Jason
Statham yeah he's ducking awesome in the
movie and what does the black guys name
from Prometheus Idris Elba yeah the guy
he's awesome villain in this what to
think
Idris Elba Idris Elba yeah yeah he's
just he's good at everything eyelid Neri
yeah well and and well dark tower but
his fault wasn't his fault no doctor but
and I wasn't too much into all that
Pacific Ram stuff but and Prometheus
that's one of my favorite movies and he
did a great job in that one it's like
the guys were likeable yeah I like that
idea
and honestly dwayne johnson has always
struck me as just like a wonderful human
being yeah you seem super he just seems
like a cool big friendly big friendly
dude
well you know it not so much friendly he
seems trustworthy yeah yeah you could
Charlie nice man nice a really cool dude
very heroic guy but yeah so like if
you've seen now I had to Wikipedia
because I was like I know that there is
like a [ __ ] ton of Fast and Furious
movies and I think I only seen the first
one but I'm like this one doesn't seem
like it has anything to do with that one
and I guess I was correct because the
first okay there have been eight movies
so far there's two more planned like the
ones gonna come out next year once think
about the year after that there have
been eight movies in the Fast and
Furious franchise now the first four I
think had to do with like street racing
which was what I thought it was about
yeah like a long time ago when I saw
this a long time ago and then they said
that it had like a soft reboot in 2009
and then they went more in the spies and
like hijack kind of direction the movie
the movie feels a lot like one of the
newer Mission Impossible movies which I
like I like this yeah the thing is
though is that there's a lot more humor
except crazier and like crazy like
almost like cartoonish yeah if you vet
pieces but if you enjoy you know Mission
Impossible maybe you know an admission
the newer Mission Impossible movies you
like yes yeah and I feel like and this
is the same director which I didn't know
but this is the same director that did
Deadpool to he also co-directed the
first John wick yeah he did atomic
blonde which I haven't seen yet that's
that that actually looked really good I
kind of wanted to see that but I never
got around to it but yeah so apparently
and here's another thing that I didn't
know that the whole Fast and the Furious
thing I mean there's there's rides
there's a ride at Universal there's
cartoons there's a TV series is all kind
of [ __ ] this is actually universals
biggest franchise it's made like five
billion dollars or something like well
this one will make a [ __ ] ton of money
on it I probably the only criticism but
honestly my favorite part of it it's
like I said just turn your brain off
it's just like a big dumb just have fun
it's like none of the [ __ ] that happens
in it could happen in real life it's
like just physics doesn't apply and just
don't worry about it it just looks cool
and yeah it looks cool like you cannot
get through airport security the way
they do did there's all kinds of with
you
my kind of laminate that's yeah it's
just it's just action-adventure for kind
of not for all ages kind of yeah I mean
yeah I don't even think they you ever
don't even think they ever sent [ __ ] in
the movie they did one time they did but
because well pg-13 you can say [ __ ] one
second one okay yeah I think you can say
I can't remember many shit's you can say
cuz they did say [ __ ] they did sir okay
yeah maybe you can say as many shits as
you want but only you can only have one
[ __ ] yeah
bunch of Awesome's I dunno the bunch of
us and they did use it bunch of awesome
scenes in the mood yeah it's just like
action set piece and then it's like a
comedic kind of thing honestly the best
part about this I mean the action scenes
are great they're hilarious
like I said they're just over-the-top
it's just like a cartoon it's like the
[ __ ] cannot happen or that goofy though
is don't worry about it you know what
I'm able especially at the end like the
whole like if you see in the trailer you
know what happens and no more goofy than
a Marvel superhero movie yeah and that's
kind of the bad guy and it's funnier
than yeah it's a lot funnier because
it's almost like it's winking at the
audience
yeah like you know you know this you can
muggles like Marvel sucks if you ask me
I think the humorous [ __ ] stale I
don't think you know it's just
jam-packed full of a bunch of [ __ ]
nothing and this one on the other hand I
like it I like it well well I kind of
feel like and from what I characters
involved what I've heard you know ever
since the reboot in 2009 the the movies
I mean this is the first spin-off
they're apparently gonna do a few more
but this is the first one they've
they've they've gone more like just more
and more over the top with each
successive movie so I kind of like that
direction they seem to be getting better
reviews now that they're going that
direction because it's not taking
themselves all that seriously but I mean
other than the great action set pieces
and stuff easily the best part of this
is Dwayne Johnson and Jason Statham
yeah like sniping at each other yeah and
there's so many great scenes of them
just like talking like with their faces
like that and there's like insulting
each other and [ __ ] like that it's
[ __ ] physical it also kind of reminds
me of like Expendables 2 and 3 yeah only
the only thing that I'm gonna dang it
for it's a little long yeah you know and
towards the very end it got a little
sentimental and it started to [ __ ]
Bob the movie down when you start
getting a little too much well they're
trying to do some like character my dad
they tried to go more towards Family
Values about families coming back
together it's just that it took a little
too long for them to do that I think
they could have just trim that down
yellow case back with this family
oh yeah yeah they love each other you
don't really like this you don't have to
wallow in the [ __ ] yeah I think you
could have cut out a good three or four
minutes of that out of the out of that
have the sentimentality and then the
speed of the movie would it kept go yeah
because soon as they get to Samoa it
kind of bogs down a little bit of a calm
let's get this let's get this big
showdown over with well they're kind of
bill yeah they building up to like the
last big rock you know last stand or
whatever and it's like I like that like
I liked all the scenes on Samoa that was
like super cool that was like it that's
like the kind of the big end piece now
they move like I said it's a little bit
long it was two hours and 16 minutes and
so I feel like it could have been but
you know it might just be because I mean
we saw this like really late at night
because the the one earlier show was
full yeah so we went to one I think it
didn't start till like 10 15 or
something like that and so we were
pretty tired yeah and basically the
whole theater was playing this movie and
[ __ ] John away three yeah well this
movie was it was in three theaters yes I
can three and then John wick was right
there I thought that was out of the
theater I think they must just brought
that back it came back just cuz it was
just because they're just that awesome
yeah but yeah that's awesome movie I
know I loved I gotta get there I like
all the it's like but and like I said
the guy that directed this co-directed
the first john way so you know the
similar kind of thing like I said if you
love this kind of crazy over-the-top
action same thing was like a lot of
comedic it's almost kind of like a cop
buddy movie like that sort of that too
um so a lot is the cop buddy turned into
spy buddy turned into their you know in
with the Expendables 2 these are guys
that are my age doing all this [ __ ] yeah
yeah I mean if I can these are starting
guys are starting to get up in age you
don't I mean it's [ __ ] funny to me
that the only credible action guys going
on right now or if I kill the younger
generation needs to start stepping up
you need guys you know
in their 20s to start [ __ ] kicking
back although sometimes I feel like it
depending on what the script is like
sometimes like for believable like James
Bond
that has to be an older dude that can't
be like a 21 year old yeah you gotta be
40 to be you've got to be kind of
grizzled yeah and like look like you've
been through some [ __ ] you got to be
four no one's gonna buy it you got to be
40 to play Bond I think pretty much I
would agree with that gotta be at least
40 yeah and you got to look kind of like
you had what you have through some [ __ ]
we have to look like you got out of the
SAS which is where he came from
right you know and you know once you're
in the SAS you're gonna be in it for a
long time you go using the east side of
13 year contract so yeah you're in your
late 30s early 40s when you get out so
like I said I feel like and even like
with the Mission Impossible movies and
like all these kind of like big action
franchises I think that might be why you
know just because it's more believable
that they've done all this stuff like I
suppose like in Mission Impossible he's
supposed to been doing it for like years
yeah years so like I said you can't
really get a 21 year old guy in this or
no one's gonna believe it because like
what he looks like he just started yeah
but you know what man oh don't you pull
me back into this you had a
twenty-something year old Conan they
kick [ __ ] ass although he did it was
like a 20 year old it is but he was I
know but he didn't us like early 20s I
think I think he might have been 20 to
122 I checked it
that [ __ ] Conan Leo with her back
then well Arnold was huge yeah that was
back when he was still pretty huge
he got smaller after that isn't that
weird I was I always remember like
looking through my parents yearbooks and
I'm like why does everybody look like
they're already 35 he looked young he
just was huge you know and Marlo made a
couple mistakes in his career even
though he's gonna go well you know you
know you
he should be shouldn't should have
[ __ ] been able to play a villain he
says I'm not gonna play after after
Terminator 1 he says that says he didn't
wanna play a villian
the thing is though is him as a villain
in Terminator 1 [ __ ] that's what made
the Terminator yeah was how scary Arnold
could be Terminator 2 so having a great
movie that is
- Miranda one with whis better that was
a Terminator movie and when Arnold was a
damn terminator and on the back of that
he's like I can't plant him more
villains because he was afraid to get
suck typecast sure and then if villains
are always defeated in the end so that
you just see an Arnold getting his ass
whipped at the end he should just like
they were talking to Rick Dalton it's
true though
but what do you [ __ ] had some that
should have had some kind of clause
where only 25% of his movies couldn't
pay he could be a villain yeah because
then you'd show some range but I
wouldn't get like sucked into this one
because there's some actors it does
happen that they just play villains all
now if I was an actor which I'm not but
and I've heard of their actors say this
they always like playing villains cuz
it's more interesting there looks like
villains are usually more complex kind
of characters maybe that's not the case
nowadays because now we have kind of
more antihero type stuff and yeah people
are more into that but I can see how it
would suck playing bad guy all the time
and dying in hand I'm getting killed all
we're getting defeated at least well you
should have been he should have been in
a movie where the bad guy lived yeah or
the bet you don't let in - better I want
bad guy want kind of like a Darth Vader
tight you could probably get away with
that more now than you could back in the
old days I feel like back in the old
days maybe not in the 70s but I feel
like there was definitely a time in the
80s and 90s where it's like no the good
guy has to win even mr. freeze and he
had to play mr. freeze they had to Jimmy
that story so mr. freeze in the end was
a good guy see I couldn't even sit
through that movie so I didn't even know
that was mr. freeze but that was just a
terrible movie I've seen like big chunks
of it but I'm like yeah I don't think I
can sit I got it on VHS
I still got laughs we were watching
Oliver Harper did a review of this I
loved his channel look like go check it
out Oliver Harper's movie retrospectives
or whatever yeah and he did a
retrospective on this and I still
remember him showing like a little clip
from like a British TV show where like
somebody came over to somebody else's
house and found the Batman of Robins
soundtrack in their house and he holds
it up in front of the guy's face
sakes what in the [ __ ] tits is this
I'm gonna have to watch Batman to Robin
one of these days just because I might
find it delightful just how bad it is
but I it was kind of like what I've seen
I was just like yeah I don't think I
have the patience for that from what I
remember of it it was almost kind of
like a really bad music video without
any music in it that sounds depressed
you know it looked like a bad music
video of the of that era yeah era that's
kind of water Seattle but I saw it on
VHS and evidently on the big screen it
looked good it's just that the writing
was [ __ ] and it was just really Zane it
was cool look at all the costumes and
the sets and stuff we're cool looking
and it didn't look too good on those old
CRT televisions on 30h nothing but
everything just ran and translate very
well and the story just sucked it was
all over the place and it was not good
that's why I'm so glad that we're like
we're getting all these old movies like
from the 70s and 80s and they're all
getting restored and like you can watch
them on blu-ray now and like how can a
man like you just saw it on cable or VHS
and looked like [ __ ] and now you're
saying it's like wow this is actually a
really good-looking movie that looks
like they actually competent you know
what they were doing whereas I never
thought they did yeah yeah a lot of them
translated real well they did like I
didn't have any idea that labyrinth
looked that good I saw it on blu-ray I
saw that in the theater yeah it's
beautiful that looks beautiful right
yeah but yeah so anyway what we're
talking about Hobbes a job yeah yeah you
know it's a little same oh it's a block
but it's an action yeah tell the popcorn
yeah like porous and [ __ ] yet Junior
Mints on it or whatever you'll be
entertained and it's just like a fun
yeah two hours and 16 minutes of oven
action good acting crazy action stuff
and like to be beefy dudes yeah
bouncing insults off each others well
terminator tall heads he also had black
and injure celibate is a genetically
super-powered yeah guy they call him
calling him black Superman
he was like The Terminator which he was
he on a motorcycle here's bunny to which
I was surprised
he was just gonna be like a glowering
villain but he was actually he was
intimidating and funny yeah Tommy a real
good villain
yeah I kind of like hope they bring him
back that I didn't actually show him die
well I don't want to spoil it you just
did I'm just kidding yeah all right so
check it out if you like that type of
thing
[Music]